comment va votre père
était très bien très très bien et va
super bien ouais on va faire une
interview mon père ce héros
[Musique]
ailleurs que la lola jeu je jouerai mon
père enfin voilà papa si tu m'excuses si
tu m'écoutes je m'excuse d'avancé
comment ça va monsieur debbouze bien
m'installer là je souhaite très mal
installé c'est très mal organisé
vous voulez boire quelque chose monsieur
debout et pas l'appel mardi
non
c'est la première fois que vous avez à
la télévision
je pose des questions bras
vous étiez quel genre de père avec jamel
tout connu charles ingalls oui
c'est pareil
ça vous est arrivé de lever la main sur
lui monsieur bourgi jambes alors là j'ai
jamais la value vilana sur mon fils
j'ai lu vie depuis le coût de la tonne
mais la main toujours le respect
il a manqué de quoi quand il était petit
j'amène hélas dû jamais il a rien elle
n'a jamais manqué de rien bon c'est vrai
nous et il disait que au quatrième il
n'avait pas dit je suis sûr mais moi je
sais qu'il a jamais été offert
vous auriez aimé qu'il fasse quoi comme
métier djamel
président de la république les suédoises
ça vous a surpris quand tu sais lancer
dans la comédie je l'aïe et je lègue
j'ai toujours dit à mon fils comédienne
si pour les [ __ ] et les homosexuels du
jeu sympa lula
vous avez réagi comment quand vous avez
vu son spectacle monsieur de blues je la
veux son spectacle oui et alors vous
quittez votre réaction parle moi de
beaucoup beaucoup d'éclat tapis tout ça
ouais
lui il voit toujours les côtes poids ne
voit pas la mort qu'il ya derrière un
c'est ça qui est dommage
ils vous aident aujourd'hui djamel
nom
jean-louis c'est pour ça je le dis à la
télévision il est pas super si c'est
pour ça que je veux quand même c'est un
bon fils quand même monsieur de bronze
mais c'est parce que tu le connais pas
c'est pour ça vous dit ça monsieur je
suis désolé monsieur drucker mois
valet
c'est pas
les relations entre deux de vos fils
jamal et momo ça se passe comment
les rapports elle sautera pas
fraternelle
jude ya mon fichier jamais le goût de la
sphère travail avec le wii s'offre à
ramleh bien sûr mais c'est vrai mais dès
là jamais travaillé six pour sa
source aux passeports et la marque et
piétons
[Musique]
joli but pareil
mais on compare souvent la famille
debbouze et la famille ewing pourquoi
bon c'est vrai je sois un peu comme
jockey weiwei mon fils ma note ça serait
un peu comme gr i way et gmail c'est un
peu comme les puits de pétrole
si un plus à leur
système quand vous voyez djamen avec les
plus grandes stars françaises ça vous
fait quoi monsieur debbouze
juge souris
complètement malade je vois bien qu'elle
glisse dans le show-business j'essaie de
lui mais j'arrive pas à le 11 le voit
avec
des stars comme
google mail par exemple qui
l'influencent mal dans le dos je veux
pas j'aime pas s'il était en face de
vous djamel vous lui diriez quoi
monsieur bush juste à côté mais les
arrières m'étais veux pas me lehner
vous nous donnez de l'argent sur ses
cachets à jamel non
80 des portions ça c'est pas grand chose
c'est ici si ces journées il ya des
choses qui va jamais osé vous dira
djamel
jusqu'à oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu